Edwyn rained most gloriously 17 years
over the Nationals of the English and
the bristles six wear of as has been
said he also as a servant in the kingdom
of Christ CAD wala
king of the Britons rebelled against him
being supported by Pender most warlike
man of the royal race of the merciless
and who from that time governed that
nation twenty-two years with various
success a great battle being fought in
the plane that is called heat field
Edwin was killed on 12th of October in
here our Lord 633 being then 47 years of
age and all his arm he was either slain
or dispersed in same war answer before
him fell was freed what sounds a warlike
you
Ian freed another of them compelled by
necessity went over to King panda and
was by him afterwards in the reign of
Oswald slain contrary to his own
at this time a great slaughter was made
in the church or nation of the
northumbrian and the more so because one
of the commanders by whom it was made
was a pagan and the other a barbarian
more cruel than a pagan for Pender with
all the nation of the merchants was an i
dollars her and a stranger to the name
of Christ but CAD wala though he bore
the name and professed himself a
Christian was so barbarous his
disposition and behavior that he neither
spare the female sex nor the innocent
age of children but with savage cruelty
put them to tormenting deaths ravaging
all their country for a long time and
resolving to cut off all the race of the
English within the borders of bristle
nor did he pay any respect to the
Christian religion which had newly taken
root among them his being to this day
the custom of the Britons not to pay any
respect to the faith and religion of the
English nor to correspond with them any
more than with pagans King Edwin's head
was brought to York and afterwards into
the Church of st. Peter the Apostle
which he had begun
but which is successor Oswald finished
as has been said before it was deposited
in the porch of st. Gregory Pope from
his disciples he had received the Word
of Life the affairs of the Northumbrian
being in confusion by reason of this
disaster without any prospect of safety
except in flight Paul Linus taking with
him Queen Ethel Berger whom he had
before brought thither returned into
Kent by sea and was honorably received
by the Archbishop hon aureus and King
oddball he came thither under the
conduct of basses a most valiant soldier
of King edwin having with him a inflator
a daughter and Wisc freya the son of
edwin as also if he the son of oz freed
his son whom afterwards the mother for
fear of IDI bald and oswald sent over
into france to be bred up by king dagger
bear who was her friend and there they
both died in infancy and were buried in
the church with the honour due to royal
children and to innocence of christ he
also brought with him many rich goods of
king edwin among which were a large gold
cross and a golden chalice dedicated to
the use of the altar which are still
preserved and shown in the Church of
Canterbury
at that time Church of Rochester had no
bishop for Romanovs the prelate there of
being sent to Pope Honorius by
Archbishop Justice as his Leggett was
drowned in the Italian sea and thereupon
Polhemus and the request of Archbishop
Honorius and King odbald
took upon him the charge of the same and
held it until he departed to heaven with
the glorious fruits of his labors and
dying in that church he left there the
poor which he received from the Pope of
Rome it left behind the minister Church
at York James the deacon
a wholly ecclesiastic were continuing
long after in that church by teaching
and baptizing rescued much prey from the
power of the old enemy of mankind from
whom the village where he mostly resided
near cataract as it's named to this day
he was extraordinarily skillful in
singing and when the province was
afterwards restored to peace and the
number of the faithful increased he
began to teach many of the church to
sing according to the custom of the
Romans or of the account to Aryans and
being old and full of days as the
scripture says he went the way of his
forefathers
[Music]